[Music]
the contents of this metal cylinder
could either revolutionize technology or
be completely useless it all depends on
whether we can harness the strange
physics of matter at very very small
scales to even have a chance of doing so
we have to control the environment
precisely the thick tabletop and legs
guard against vibrations from footsteps
nearby elevators and opening or closing
doors the cylinder is a vacuum chamber
devoid of all the gases in the air
inside the vacuum chamber is a smaller
extremely cold compartment reachable by
tiny laser beams inside our ultra
sensitive particles that make up a
quantum computer so what makes these
particles worth the effort in theory
quantum computers could outstrip the
computational limits of classical
computers classical computers process
data in the form of bits each bit can
switch between two states labeled 0 & 1
a quantum computer uses something called
a qubit which can switch between 0 1 and
what's called a super position while the
qubit is in its super position it has a
lot more information than 1 or 0 you can
think of these positions as points on a
sphere the North and South Poles of the
sphere represent 1 & 0 a bit can only
switch between these two poles but when
a qubit is in its superposition it can
be at any point on the sphere we can't
locate it exactly the moment we read it
the qubit resolves into a 0 or a 1 but
even though we can't observe the qubit
in its superposition we can manipulate
it to perform particular operations
while in this state so as a problem
grows more complicated a classical
computer needs correspondingly more bits
to solve it while a quantum computer
will theoretically be able to handle
more and more complicated problems
without requiring as many more qubits as
a classical computer would need bits the
unique properties of quantum computers
result from the behavior of atomic and
subatomic particles these particles have
quantum states which correspond to the
state of the qubit quantum states are
incredibly fragile easily destroyed by
temperature
and pressure fluctuations stray
electromagnetic fields and collisions
with nearby particles
that's why quantum computers needs such
an elaborate setup it's also why for now
the power of quantum computers remains
largely theoretical so far we can only
control a few qubits in the same place
at the same time there are two key
components involved in managing these
fickle quantum states effectively the
types of particles a quantum computer
uses and how it manipulates those
particles for now there are two leading
approaches trapped ions and
superconducting qubits a trapped ion
quantum computer uses ions as its
particles and manipulates them with
lasers the ions are housed in a trap
made of electrical fields inputs from
the lasers tell the ions what operation
to make by causing the cubed state to
rotate on the sphere to use a simplified
example the lasers could input the
question what are the prime factors of
15 in response the ions may release
photons the state of the qubit
determines whether the ion emits photons
and how many photons it emits an imaging
system collects these photons and
processes them to reveal the answer
three and five superconducting qubit
quantum computers do the same thing in a
different way using a chip with
electrical circuits instead of an ion
trap the states of each electrical
circuit translate to the state of the
qubit they can be manipulated with
electrical inputs in the form of
microwaves so the qubits come from
either ions or electrical circuits acted
on by either lasers or microwaves each
approach has advantages and
disadvantages ions can be manipulated
very precisely and they last a long time
but as more ions are added to a trap it
becomes increasingly difficult to
control each with precision
we can't currently contain enough ions
in a trap to make advanced computations
but one possible solution might be to
connect many smaller traps that
communicate with each other via photons
rather than trying to create one big
trap
superconducting circuits meanwhile make
operations much faster than trapped ions
and it's easier to scale up the number
of circuits in a computer than the
number of ions but the circuits are also
more fragile and have a shorter overall
lifespan and as quantum computers
advance they will still be subject to
the environmental constraints needed to
preserve quantum states but in spite of
all of these obstacles we've already
succeeded in making computations in a
realm we can't enter or even observe
dive deeper into the world of quantum
mechanics with this playlist
[Music]